There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time, so we gathered
some of the most-hyped
products from October
to test for ourselves.
Let's start off with these new products
from Huda Beauty's GloWish line,
the Luminous Pressed Powder
and the Cheeky Vegan Blush.
I have yet to be disappointed
by a GloWish product,
but this powder wasn't my favorite.
It is super silky and
soft, but I felt like
because it's a luminous pressed powder,
on my bare skin, it
just highlighted texture
in a way I didn't love.
I had a feeling I would like
this more over foundation --
you can use it both ways --
so I tried it that way, and, yep,
I feel like it looks
smoother over the foundation
than just on my bare skin.
And the blush was cute,
nothing really special.
I don't think it's worth paying $21
for a just-OK blush,
especially one that's so baby-sized.
This water-activated
liner from Matte Lashes
is supposed to be super
pigmented and transfer-proof,
so I was dying to try it out.
All you do with these is
dip your brush in some water
and wet the liner.
I put some on the back of my hand first
just to see how
transfer-proof it actually is,
and it did not move.
It also dried down super
matte, which I love.
I hate when black liner has
that shiny satin finish.
Applying it on the eyes was so easy.
I actually prefer using
these kinds of liners,
because I feel like
I just have more control of the product.
I can see myself using this all the time,
and it actually comes in a set
with a white liner too.
This is a product that I don't think
I ever would have tried
if it wasn't for this show.
This is the Makeup by Mario
Master Metals Eyeshadow Palette,
and it has all these really
beautiful metallic shades
that can be used wet or dry.
I used this orange copper shade dry first,
just applying it straight
on the eye with my finger,
and these are so smooth and metallic.
They really do make your eyes pop.
Then I scraped up some powder
to mix together with the Metal Manipulator
to basically turn it into a liquid.
This is sold separately, by the way.
Using these in the liquid form
intensifies it by, like, 1,000.
It literally looks like
liquid metal on the eyes.
And the Metal Manipulator
makes it budge-proof,
so it won't smudge anywhere.
I'm still not super into the idea
of a $48 all-metallic palette,
but the quality of these
shadows is so, so good.
Next, let's talk about
the Milani Color Fetish Matte Lipsticks.
Oh, my God, I think I love these.
They are incredibly creamy,
smooth, and pigmented.
I love the soft matte finish they have.
Everything about these
feels more expensive
than they actually are.
They are so cute.
Definitely recommend these.
This color, Secret, in particular
is supposed to be a Charlotte
Tilbury Pillow Talk dupe.
I can't speak on that
because I don't have Pillow Talk money,
but I'm just letting you know.
And, finally, we have the
Em Cosmetics So Soft sticks.
I have the Multi Faceplay stick,
which can be used as bronzer or contour,
and the blush stick.
The name does not lie.
These are some of the softest,
most easy-to-blend
products I've ever used.
I don't normally contour,
but this color was more on the cool side,
so I attempted to contour with it,
and it was just so easy
to apply and blend.
Same with the blush.
The color was a little too light for me,
but because they blend in so easy,
I think I made it work.
These are pricey,
but so worth it to me.